[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاده ليله معكم زين العابدين
توفيق وبينما نتحدث الان تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى نبدا من هذه الصور المباشره
من جنين بالضفه الغربيه وذلك بعد اقتحام
قوات الاحتلال لمخيمها في عمليه اللافته
في حجمها وايضا في مدتها اذ استمرت ساعات
قتل الاحتلال خمسه فلسطينيين واصيب ثمانيه
من جنوده بجروح
من اليونان تحديدا من مدينه كلماتا نتابع
هذه الصور مع بدء القضاء اليونانيه اولى
جلسات التحقيق في ماساه غرق قارب يقل مئات
من طالب اللجوء قباله السواحل البلاد
في مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قوات الاحتلال تقتل خمسه فلسطينيين في
اقتحام جرين وتدفع بقوات البريه وجويه في
عمليه استمرت ساعات وتلجا لاول مره منذ 20
عاما لاستخدام المروحيات اصابه ثمانيه من
جنود الاحتلال واعطاب سبع اليات خلال
الاشتباكات
والمقاومه تتواعد باسلحه تفاجئ الاحتلال
قلق اوروبي وتحذير اممي من تصعيد يدخل
المنطقه في ازمه خطيره
مع تحذير غوتيرش من غرق السودان في الموت
والدمار بشكل متسارع تعهدات بمليار ونصف
مليار دولار في مؤتمر للدعم الانساني
بمشاركه قطر والسعوديه والولايات المتحده
وفي ثاني ايام الهدنه الجديده هدوء يخيم
على ساحات المعارك في السودان الجيش يرفض
دعوه كيليه لعقد اجتماع لوزراء خارجيه
الاليه الرباعيه الافريقيه
لينك يختتم زياره هي الاولى لوزير خارجيه
امريكيه لبيجين منذ خمس سنوات والرئيس
الصيني يؤكد ان محادثات البلدين تحرز
تقدما وبلينك يشدد على ان واشنطن لا تدعم
استقلال تايوان ويقول ان الصين لم توافق
حتى الان على استئناف الاتصالات العسكريه
المباشره
على وقع معارك محتدمه شرقا وجنوبا القوات
الاوكرانيه تؤكد تقدمها باتجاه باخمت رغم
الحشود العسكريه الروسيه وتقول انها
استعارت بلده جنوب غربي
وموسكو تعلن السيطره على مدينه في
دوناتسكا بشكل كامل بعد صد هجوم اوكراني
هي لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا التطورات في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه تحديدا في مدينه جنين التي
اقتحمتها قوات الاحتلال وقتلت خمسه
فلسطينيين واسقطت العشرات من الجرحى في
عمليه استخدمت فيها المروحيات للمره
الاولى منذ اكثر من عشرين عاما واصيب فيها
ايضا ثمانيه من جنود الاحتلال احدهم في
حاله خطره واعطت 7 اليات من اليات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اراكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
ما دلالات الاستخدام العسكري المفرط لقوات
بريه وجويه في هذا الاقتحام 70% راوا انه
مؤشر على نيه التصعيد الاسرائيلي بشكل
كبير وراء الثلاثون بالمئه انه مؤشر على
تعقد المواجهات بسبب تناوي قدره المقاومين
داخل الضفه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز الكيو ار الظاهر الان على الشاشه
لقائنا في المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيه ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا بعد محادثات
لاكثر من 15 عاما الامم المتحده تتبنى اول
معاهده عالميه لحمايه اعالي البحار
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم البدايه من الاراضي
الفلسطينيه التي شهدت لاول مره منذ 20
عاما لجوء قوات الاحتلال الى سلاح الجو في
اقتحامها لمخيم جنين بالضفه الغربيه
الاشتباكات التي اعقبت الاقتحام امتدت
ساعات قتلت خلالها قوته الاحتلال خمسه
فلسطينيين واعلنت عن اصابه ثمانيه من
جنودها واعطاء بسبع من الياتها تطور
الاحداث في جنين صباح اليوم نتعرف عليه في
هذا التقرير
دخول قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الى جنين
ومخيمها لم يكن نزهه سهله فعلى مدار 10
ساعات تحولت اطراف المخيم الغربيه الى
ساحه معركه بين قوات الاحتلال والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه
عمليه عسكريه استهدفت اعتقال مطلوبين
اثنين لدى قوات الاحتلال بتهمه تنفيذه
هجمات مسلحه ضد اهداف اسرائيليه
عبوات ناسفه محليه الصنع فجرها مقاومون
فلسطينيون في طريق الاليات العسكريه اسفرت
عن اعطاب خمس منها واصابه سبعه جنود
اسرائيليين
الطيران المروحي الاسرائيلي شن غاره جويا
لاول مره منذ اكثر من عشرين عاما في محيط
احد المساجد في حي الجابريات لتامين اجلاء
الجرحى
خمسه شهداء وعشرات الجرحى بينهم صحفي
سقطوا برصاص الاحتلال بينما تعرضت مؤسسات
طبيه ومحيطها في المخيم لرصاص الاحتلال
الاصابات كانت في الاطراف العلويه من
الجسم منها مكان في الراس منها في الرقبه
وهنالك عده اصابات كانت بالصدر والبطن
العمليه العسكريه خلفت دمارا في ممتلكات
الفلسطينيين واستهدفت قوات الاحتلال موقع
استشهاد الزميله شيرين ابو عاقله فصائل
فلسطينيه واوساط رسميه نددت بجرائم
الاحتلال وقالت ان التصعيد الاسرائيلي لم
ياتي من فراغ
وطالما شعر الجناه والقتل بالافلات من
العقاب لن تتوقف جرائمه نحن وشعبنا سوف
نتصدى لهذه الهجمات ولابد من ان يصبح هذا
الاحتلال مكلف لاسرائيل
وعقبا انسحاب قوات الاحتلال من جنين شيعت
جماهير المدينه جثامنا شهدائها وسط حاله
من الغضب عدد من الشهداء والجرحى سقطوا
بنيران قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في جنين
وحلت غضب تعم الاراضي الفلسطينيه كل ذلك
جاء وسط حاله ارباك سادت الاوساط الامنيه
والسياسيه الاسرائيليه حيال فشل قواتها في
الخروج من هذه العمليه دون خسائر سمير ابو
شماله الجزيره من مخيم جنين فلسطين
الاذاعه العسكريه الاسرائيليه قالت ان
الجيش سيفتح تحقيقا لاستخلاص الدروس مما
جرى اليوم في جليل ونقل موقع ولاعه المصدر
في القياده الوسطى الاسرائيليه القول ان
قواعد اللعبه قد تغيرت بعد هذه العمليه
حسب تعبيره تقرير التالي يعيد بناء المشهد
الميداني ليحاكي ماجر اليوم في جنين
صباح
تتمركز قوه عسكريه اسرائيليه كبيره في حي
الجابريات عند الاطراف الجنوبيه الغربيه
لمخيم جنين تمهيدا لاقتحامه
ينشر الجيش الاسرائيلي قناصه على اسطح بعض
المنازل ليبدا الاقتحام بتوهل قوه الى
داخل المخيم
بالتزامن ترصد فصائل المقاومه تسلل عناصر
من المستعربين فتشتبك معهم لينطلق الهجوم
الواسعه
نجحت الفصائل الفلسطينيه في محاصره القوه
المتمركزه في الجابريات والشبكت مع
عناصرها
واعترض مقاومون اليه عسكريه كانت تتحرك في
شارع الجابريات واعطبوها بمفخخه محليه
الصنع تقدر زينتها بنحو اربعين كيلو جراما
واستهدفوا مصفحه اخرى بقذيفه اخترقتها
بشكل مباشر واسفرت عن اصابه عدد من الجنود
الاسرائيليين
ترافقت محاولات فك الحصار عن القوه
الاسرائيليه مع اشتداد حده الاشتباكات
واضطر جيش الاحتلال لطلب تعزيزات وللمره
الاولى منذ عقدين استخدمت قوات الاحتلال
مروحيات عسكريه في قصف جنين ما ادى الى
سقوط قتلى وجرحى وقال الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني ان سيارات عسكريه حاولت
الاصطدام بسيارات الاسعاف واطلقت الرصاصه
الحي لمنع نقل الجرحى اللافت في الاشتباك
من الجانب الفلسطيني دخول اسلحه محليه
الصنع بهذا الحجم حيز الاستخدام لم يكشف
عنها من قبل ومن بينها قذائف مضاده للدروع
وعبوات شديده الانفجار لتكون المفاجاه
الابرز اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي اصابه
مروحيه عسكريه في العمليه واعطاب سبع
اليات مدرعه الاذاعه العسكريه نقلت ان
الجيش سيفتح تحقيقا لاستخلاص الدروس وقال
موقع والا نقلا عن مصدر في القياده الوسطى
الاسرائيليه ان قواعد اللعبه قد تغيرت بعد
هذه العمليه
هذا وادنت الخارجيه الفلسطينيه عدوان
الاحتلال المتواصل على الفلسطينيين في
محافظه جنين وغيرها من المناطق واضافت ان
الاحتلال استخدم الرصاص الحي والمروحيات
الحربيه معتبره ذلك تصعيدا خطيره
وعلى وقع تحذير الامومي من تصعيد يدخل
المنطقه في ازمه خطيره اعرب الاتحاد
الاوروبي عن قلقه ازاء الاحداث الاخيره في
جنين والتي ادت الى سقوط عدد من الضحايا
المدنيين وقال الاتحاد في بيان انه يجب ان
تكون العمليات العسكريه متناسبه ومتوافقه
مع القانون الانساني الدولي واضاف انه
يشعر بالقلق من خطه اسرائيل المعلنه لبناء
اكثر من اربعه الاف وحده استيطانيه في
الضفه الغربيه بنهايه يونيو حزيران الجاري
دعيه ان اسرائيل الى عدم المضي قدما في
ذلك
من رام الله لنا دكتور غسان الخطيب استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه بيرزيت كما ينضم
الينا لاحقا من برلين توماس نيلس مدير
المبادره الالمانيه للشرق الاوسط ابدا بك
دكتور غسان
الذي تحقق في جنين اليوم من جانب المقاومه
هل هو
مؤشر على المستقبل والى اي درجه هو يؤشر
على ذلك
الحقيقه ابرز ما جرى اليوم في جنين هو ان
اسرائيل اخذت خطوه اضافيه
باتجاه تصعيد السمه الاساسيه التي ميزت
سياستها سياسه هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
وهي القتل
اسرائيل اليوم مسؤوله عن اعدام خمسه
فلسطينيين واصابه عشرات من الفلسطينيين
اضافه للدمار الشامل الذي خلفته هذه
الهجمه الاسرائيليه ولكن بطبيعه الحال لفت
الانتباه ايضا الى ان هذه الامور لم تكن
سهله لانه ايضا الجهات الفلسطينيه التي
سارعت للتصدي وللدفاع عن جنين ومخيمها
ايضا اظهرت تطورا نوعيا من خلال
ما شاهدناه من تفجير لعبوه ناففه ومن
اصابه لمروحيه اسرائيليه
هذا التطور يشير الى اننا مقبلون على
مرحله تصعيد لانه اسرائيل غالبا لن تقبل
بهذه المعادله وستحاول كسرها والطرف الاخر
اي الطرف الفلسطيني المقاوم ايضا سوف
يستمر بتطوير امكانياته وبالتالي على
الاغلب اننا مقبلون على مزيد من التصعيد
خصوصا لان هذه الحكومه معنيه بالتصعيد
لاسباب داخليه اسرائيليه ولانه الشباب
الفلسطيني ايضا يعني ليس لديه اي افاق لا
اقتصاديه ولا سياسيه
تبرر يعني
وقف مثل هذه
الوقفات المقاومه الصلبه طبعا اسرائيل
استخدمت المروحيات والطيران لاول مره منذ
2002 منذ عمليه الدرع الواقي التي قامت
بها اسرائيل في الضفه الغربيه في جنين
تحديدا واسفرت عن قتل مئات الفلسطينيين
ربما 500 بحسب السلطه الفلسطينيه وايضا
قتل 23 جنديا اسرائيليا 14 منهم قتلوا في
يوم واحد 12 او 12 منهم قتلوا في كمين
واحد في في جنين حينما نتحدث عن تطور
المقاومه
نتحدث عن تطور يصل الى هذا المستوى الذي
اوقع 12 جنديا اسرائيليا في كمين الواحد
في تقدير بانه المؤشرات تشير الى
احتماليه التصعيد في هذا الاتجاه من الصعب
تقدير التفاصيل ولكن بالمجمل
بالنظر الى الواقع الفلسطيني وبالنظر الى
واقع هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه فان كل
المؤشرات تشير الى اننا في اتجاه تصعيد
خصوصا بانه في هذه المرحله بالذات وخلاف
المراحل السابقه لا يوجد طرف ثالث يتدخل
لمحاوله تهدئه الوضع معالجه الوضع ايجاد
مقترحات من النوع الذي يمكن ان يسحب
الفتيل وبالتالي الطرفين في حاله تحفز ولا
يوجد طرف ثالث اذا نحن يعني سوف نشهد مزيد
من التصعيد وربما احداث اليوم هي مؤشر على
ما سياتي في المراحل القريبه القادمه
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا الدكتور غسان الخطيب
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه دير الزيت
ضيفنا من رام الله نرحب بضيفنا من برلين
توماس نيلز مدير المبادره الالمانيه للشرق
الاوسط يعني حينما يتحدث بهذا الاتحاد
الاوروبي عن الاحداث ما الذي يقصده
بالاحداث لماذا لا يوجد لغه واضحه بان
هنالك اقتحام لمخيم لا يقع تحت السيطره
الاسرائيلي يقع في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
وفق القوانين الدوليه
الاتحاد الاوروبي على الارجح يتردد في
استخدام العبارات الواضحه على سبيل المثال
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الالمانيه
دان ايضا هذه
الاحداث
وعرب عن اسفه لسقوط ضحايا ولكن في الوقت
نفسه لم يذكر كلمه تصعيد فقط وصف التصعيد
كما هو وكما اشرتم
واستخدام المروحيات العسكريه واستخدام
الاسلحه الثقيله الاخرى بالاضافه الى
السلوك المتشدد من قبل الجنود
الاسرائيليين وبالتالي هذه امور اكثر مما
كانت تحصل في الماضي واستمعت الى التقرير
وذكر التقرير هذه العمليه وايضا لكن سيء
المانيا
لغه اوروبا لو تسمح لي لغه اوروبا ولغه
امريكا واضحه جدا في صراع اخر هو الصراع
الروسي الاوكراني واضحه جدا في ادانت
الاعمال الروسيه وادانه كل التصرفات
الروسيه باوضح العبارات واكثرها قوه لكن
في موضوع اسرائيل لماذا لا يوجد هذا
الوضوح
لربما في برلين في ذاكره التاريخ الالماني
وايضا في ذاكره الاوروبيه لربما هذه
الاحداث غير حاضره وبالتالي لا اعرف
الاجابه ولكن انت على حق بالنسبه الى
روسيا بالنسبه الى ما يحصل في اوكرانيا
هناك عقوبات وهناك وصف دقيق للاعتداء
الروسي ولكن في هذه الحاله الامر لا ينطبق
لسنوات كنا نستمع الى تصريحات مماثله في
المانيا على سبيل المثال التصريحات تشهير
دائما الى حل الدولتين ولكن ما من احد
يعرف اذا ما كان سوف يحصل هذا الاحل وما
من احد ايضا دانه افعال الوزير سموتش في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وهو وحده تقريبا
يمكنه ان يتفاوض وهذا يعتمد على ماذا
سيستمنين هل يعتمد هذا الفارق في استخدام
اللغه الواضحه مع روسيا وعدم استخدامها مع
اسرائيل وعدم الادانه يرجع الى ماذا يرجع
الى
كونها اسرائيل قبل الكون ان خصومها من
العالم العربي والاسلاميه يعني ما السبب
هل في طبيعه خصوم اسرائيل ام في طبيعه
اسرائيل
ولكنني هنا اعبر عن وجهه نظري الشخصيه هذا
الامر مرده ايضا لان فلسطين ليست دوله
معترف بها مثل اوكرانيا اذا اسرائيل
وضعها يختلف
ويتم الاشاره الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه من
جهه اخرى ربما هذا هو الفرق الاساسي اشكرك
شكرا جزيلا من برلين توماس مصر مدير
المبادره الالمانيه للشرق الاوسط
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات في السودان تعهد المارحون في
مؤتمر الجنيف للاستجابه الطارئه للازمه في
السودان بتقديم مبلغ مليار ونصف المليار
دولار وفي كلمته خلال الاجتماع عبر الامين
العامله للامم المتحده عن قلقه من استهداف
العاملين في المجال الانساني داعيا اطراف
الصراع وحكومات الدول المجاوره للسودان
الى حمايه المدنيين وتسهيل عمل المنظمات
الانسانيه نبا غوتيرش ايضا الى ان السودان
يغرق في الموت والدمار بشكل متسارع على حد
تعبيره
يطالب جميع الاطراف في الصراع بالالتزام
بحمايه المدنيين وتمكين العاملين في
المجال الانساني من اجراء عملياتهم وفق
القانون الدولي والانساني فان العمليات
الانسانيه محميه لذلك ادعو جميع الاطراف
وحكومات الدول المجاوره للقيام بما في
وسعهم لمساعده العاملين في المجال
الانساني من اجل الوصول الى كل المحتاجين
للمساعدات في السودان
رئيسه مجلس الوزراء ووزير الخارجيه
القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني
في كلمته امام الاجتماع اعلنت تعهد قطر
بتقديم 50 مليون دولار لدعم خطه الاستجابه
الطارئه في السودان
وانطلاقا من مسؤولياتنا الاخويه وواجبنا
الاخلاقي والانساني تجاه الاشقاء في
السودان ومواصله لجهودنا الانسانيه
والالمائيه المستمره في السودان الشقيق
نعلن عن تعهد دوله قطر بمبلغ 50 مليون
دولار امريكي وذلك لدعم جهود خطه
الاستجابه الانسانيه والخطه الاقليميه
للاجئين
ومن جهه ثانيه قال وزير خارجيه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان ان المملكه ستواصل سعيها
لحل الازمه في السودان واضاف ان مركز
الملك سلمان تعهد بتقديم 100 مليون دولار
للدعم الانسانيه في السودان
ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه حكومه شعبه
اطلاقا من مبادئها في دعمي واغاثه الاشقاء
الى الاصدقاء تم تدخل جهدا في دعم الشعب
السوداني الشقيق منذ بدايه الازمه
بقيمه 100 مليون دولار من خلال مركز الملك
سلمان والاعمال الانسانيه ووفق
اليوم في جنيف يفتحوا الباب على اسئله على
المستوى الوضع الذي وصل اليه السودان مع
استمرار المعارك للشهر الثالث على التوالي
ماذا يقال عن بلد نصف سكانه بحاجه
للمساعدات بلد يشهد معارك عنيفه منذ شهرين
زادت من الازمه وعمقت المعاناه قرابه 25
مليون سوداني يحتاجون المساعده والحمايه
وفق ارقام المنظمات الدوليه الانسانيه
بسبب المعارك غادر قرابه من مليونين ونصف
مليون انسان منازله من بين هؤلاء مليون
و900 الف شخص نزحوا داخل حدود السودان
بينما اضطر اكثر من نصف مليون شخص الى
عبور الحدود تتحرك الارقام متزايدا مع
استمرار المعارك وتعمق المعاناه اكثر
المناطق تضررا في البلاد العاصمه الخرطوم
تاقليم دارفور غربا واقليم كردفان جنوبه
الخرطوم يقول برنامج الاغذيه العالمي ان
نصف مليون شخص ينتظرون المساعده العاجله
الاف من هؤلاء محاصرون في منازلهم
والاحياء التي تشهد اشتباكات خصوصا محيطا
مقر السياديه ومدينه ام درمان شرقي
العاصمه
الغربيه البلاد يبدو المشهد اكثر قتاما في
اقليم دارفور يعيش الناس كابوسا بحسب وصف
الامين العام للامم المتحده هناك تسعه
ملايين شخص بحاجه لمساعده عاجله يقول احد
المسؤولين الامميين ان مدينه الجنينه
عاصمه ولايه غرب دارفور تمثل نموذجا
للماساه في الاقليم فهناك صراعات القبليه
تضاف الى المعارك الدائره بين الجيش
والدعم السريع موضوع هش في الاقليم وغير
مستقر في اماكن اخرى في الفاشر ونيال
وزلنجي لكن تمت ما هو اكثر صعوبه من كل
هذه الارقام والتفاصيل يناشد العاملون في
المجال الانساني اطراف الصراع والدول
المجاوره التدخل لحمايتهم وحمايه
المساعدات يقول مسؤول الاممي ان مكاتب
الامم المتحده ودور ضيافتها تعرضت للقصف
بينما نهب مجرمون مكاتب اخرى وسرقوا
سيارات ومستودعات واحرق مرافقه تابعه
للمنظمات الدوليه هكذا يتعقد المشهد في
السودان مع تباطؤ المساعدات المقدمه
الطلبه الامم المتحده مليارين و600 مليون
دولار لتبقى الازمه الانسانيه في السودان
تتعمق اكثر واكثر مع استمرار المعارك
في تحركات الحل السياسيه اعلنت وزاره
الخارجيه السودانيه رفضها دعوه وجهها وزير
الخارجيه الكيني لعقد اجتماع اليوم لوزاره
خارجيه الاليه الرباعيه المكلفه بحل ازمه
السودانيه واكلت الخارجيه السودانيه ان
السودان غير معني بلا اجتماع لانه لا يزال
في انتظار رد بشان اعتراضه على رئاسه
كينيا للاليه وابدت الخارجيه السودانيه
اعتراضها على وصف كينيا للازمه السودانيه
بانها قتال بين جنرلين وصفه التسميه
بالمخله وصفت الوزاره تعاطي الحكومه
تركنيه مع ملف الوساطه بانه متسرع وفيه
تجاوز لمبدا احترام السياده الدول حسب
قولها
هذا وداع الرئيس الشاذلي محمد ادريس ديبي
في تصريحا للجزيره طرفي الصرع في السودان
الى وقف الحرب وتغليبي لغه الحوار لاعاده
الامن والاستقرار للبلاد
في الحرب
لله سبحانه وتعالى
عشان
قاعده
الناس كلها تعبانين
السوداني
نطلب منهم خليه يقف الهرب واهليه بحجه
الهجره خير من هرب
نرحب بالاستديو بضيفنا مزمل ابو القاسم
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني اذا
مليار ونصف مليار دولار في مؤتمر جنيف
للمانحين ما الذي يمكن ان يصل منهم الى
السودانيين المتضررين
للشعب السوداني تجربه طويله وغير مبشره مع
مؤتمرات
المانحين اذ قلما تتحول الى واقع اذا كان
قائد قوات الدعم السريع وقد توعد الشعب
السوداني قبل الحرب بمطر بدون براك
فمؤتمرات المانحين غالبا ما تتحول الى
براد من دون مطر خلال فتره الانتقاليه
هذا مطر كثير هذه وعود بامطار نتحول نتمنى
ان تمطر دعما دعما المتحده الامير العام
للمتحده ذكر انهم بحي الى ثلاثه مليارات
المانحين وعدوا بتقديم نصفها ولكن في
الغالب قلما تاتي تلك المبالغ كلها
على ايام حكومه حمدو في الفتره الانتقاليه
تمت تنظيم ثلاثه مؤتمرات مماثله لمانحين
واصدقاء السودان وما اتى لخزينه الدوله لم
الامم المتحده انطونيش وصف الوضع بالسودان
بانه يغرق في بحر من الدمار والموت وان
هنالك اعتداءات متواصله ومستمره على عمال
الاغاثه هل تعتقد اذا تحققت هذه الوعود
ووجدت هذه الاموال بحوزه الامم المتحده ان
الطريق ممهده لان تصل بالفعل الى محتاجيها
محتاجيها في تشاد محتجيه في اماكن النزوح
داخل السودان
كان ان تصل الى المحتاجين اليها في تشاد
لان تشاد فتحت ممرات انسانيه ممكن ان تقدم
عبر المطارين جمينا ايضا في السودان مطار
بورسودان ميناء بورسودان مطارات شمال
السودان حتى مطار وادي سيدنا مفتوح وعامل
ومع ذلك لم يصل الى السودان الا نذر يسير
من المساعدات الانسانيه خلال الفتره
الماضيه ملايين النازحين
نزحوا الى مدن قريبه من الخرطوم فيها قتال
مثل شندي وعبره والدامر وبربر
ودنقله شمالا والكاملين والحصاحيصه ومدني
وكوستي جنوبا ولم تصل اي مساعدات حرب
وفيها ايضا دعواته ومبادرات للسلام واريد
ان احدثك عن هذه النقطه مبادره الايجاد
الاليه الرباعيه كيف كيف نفهم بيان
الخارجيه السودانيه اذا كان الخارجيه
السودانيه تقول ان السودان معترض على
رئاسه كينيا لان كينيا وصفت ما يجري بانه
حرب بين جنرال
نائب رئيس مجلس السياده يقول الفريق حمدان
حميدتي والفريق البرهان هو يتحدث عن
فريقين ايضا متحاربين فما المشكله في
الوساطه الكينيه والرئاسه الكينيه للاليه
الرباعيه بخصوص ما ذكرته اولا عن ان البلد
في حاله حرب هذه المدن وهذه المدن امنه
والوصول اليها ميسور والطرق اليها مفتوحه
ولم تصل اي غاسه اما بخصوص الم فهي لم
تقوم متوازنه ابتداعا معلوم ان الرئيس
الكيني يرتبط بعلاقات بيزنس ضخمه مع حماتي
والموقف الكيني لم يكن متزنا منذ البدايه
فيه كان تجاوز للكثير من الاعراف
الدبلوماسيه خلال هذه الحرب اعتدت قوات
الدعم السريعه على السفير الكيني داخل
الخرطوم بالضبط وسلبت منزله
وهدد زوجته
ولم تعلن كينيا حتى ذلك الخبر لانها
استهدفت التغطيه على ما يفعله الدعم سريع
في الخرطوم وبالتالي فان اللهجه التي تحدث
بها وزير خارجيه كينيا وقبله الرئيس
الكيني كانت مليئه بالوعيد والتهديد ولا
يجوز للوسيط ان ان يتحدث بلغه وعيد وتحديد
وان يرفع العصا في وجه من يرغب في التوسط
معهم الموقف الكيني لم يكن متوازنا والرفض
الرفض السوداني له ط بيعي ومتوقع يعني ليس
فقط موضوع الحرب بين الجنر هو اكبر من ذلك
نشكرك شكرا جزيلا المزمر ابو القاسم
الكاتب المحاليل الاساسي السدلي ضيفنا في
الاستوديو
ينضمرون عبد القادر محمد علي الباحث
المختص في الشان الافريقي ورده معك من هذه
النقطه استاذ عبد القادر
تحفظ الحكومه السودانيه على الرئاسه
الكليه للاليه الرباعيه وعالم مبادره
الايجاد ما هي الجذور
وما هو هي الاسباب الاخرى
تحفظ السودان ممثله في السيد البرهان
وحكومته على مبادره الايجاد وعلى الوساطه
الكنيه
مرحبا
على الاستضافه الحقيقه انه يعني هذا
الخلاف الحال بين السودان وبين الجيش
السوداني
والكينيا لا يمكن فهمه بمعزل عن كيفيه نظر
الطرفين الى اسرع الحالي الدائره في
السودان
الحكومه السودانيه او
مجلس السياده السوداني يرى ان كينيا هي
طرف غير محايد ويستند الى مجموعه من
الخطوات التي اتخذتها كينيا وكذلك
التصريحات على سبيل المثال
التصريحات التي صدرت عن الرئيس الكيني
ووزير الخارجيه الكيني وفيها تسويه بين
طرفي الصراع والحكومه السودانيه تطالب
يعني او ترى بعيدا عن التسويه لانه تحدثنا
في هذه التسويه
وذكرت لضيفنا السابق ما قاله مالك عقار
قال الاجتماع سيتم بين الفريق محمد حمدان
الحميتي والفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان يعني
اذا كان جزء من الحكومه
يسمي الطرفين بنفس المسمى فما بالنا
بالاطراف الخارجيه لكن ما هي الجذور
الاخرى لانه كينيا لم يكن لها مشاكل كبيره
مع السودان من قبل
الحقيقه نعم وانا كنت ساتحدث عن ايضا
الرؤيه الكينيه للصراع في السودان وفيها
تكمن نقاط الخلافه الاساسيه بمعنى ان
في الملاسنه التي تمت بين الرئيس الكيني
والوحده السوداني في قمه الايجاب تحدث
الرئيس الكيني بصراحه انه ينكر شرعيه طرفي
الصراع اليهما وان الجيش السوداني انقلب
على حكومه مدنيه وان
حميدتي ايضا تمرد على السلطه انقلابيه
فهذا احد الاسباب التي تدفع الجيش
السوداني الى رفض عذرا عذرا للمقاطعه وهل
هذا موقف متفرد هذا هو موقف العالم كله
اعتقد انه لو تحدثنا في الاطار الايجاد
اعتقد ان هناك بعض الاطراف التي تشاركيني
هذا
التوجه لكنها لم تصرح به ايضا على المستوى
الخارجي اعتقد ان المبادرات التي يتم
الحديث عنها والعمل عليها الان فيها نوع
من التسويه بين الطرف ولذلك راينا مالك
عقار تقريبا في القاهره اعلن ان كل
المبادرات
تهدوا في الاحتلال السوداني وامس اعلن ان
اي وجود اجنبي في السودان مرفوض وهذا
يحيلنا الى احد المقترحات الكيمياء باخراج
طرفي الصراع من الخرطوم واحلال شرطه مدنيه
وقوات من الاجاده اعتقد مكانهما
للفصل بين المتحاربين والبدء في عمليه
التفاوض فهذا احد الجوانب التي تؤدي الى
هذه الازمه بين الطرفين كما ذكرت كيفيه
الازمه وكيفيه حل الازمه ايضا في ما يتعلق
بالاطراف الاخرى الاطراف التي كانت منخرطه
سابقا وربما تقول لا تزال منخرطه كمصر
مثلا الامارات ما الذي تغير في مواقف هذه
الدول من الازمه
من الازمه السودانيه حتى الان لا يبدو ان
هناك تغير كبير هناك نشاط
دبلوماسي يتم العديد من الاطراف النصر
والامارات السعوديه وغيرها وهناك شبه
اجماع على المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه
والان على المبادره التي تقوم بها الاليه
الموسعه
التي تضم الايجاد والاتحاد الافريقي
والاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا
الجامعه العربيه لكن بهذين الموقف كل من
القاهره وابوظبي من الصراع الدائري في
السودان الان لا يبدو ان هناك اي تغيرات
جاذبيه في شكرا جزيلا لك عبد القادر محمد
علي الباحث المختصاد الافقي ضيفنا بن
تورنتو
[موسيقى]
في ملف التوتر الصيني الامريكيه قال البيت
الابيض ان وزير الخارجيه
محادثات صريحه وبناءه مع الرئيس الصيني
ومسؤولين اخرين وانه لا تغيير في سياسه
الصين الواحده وان واشنطن لا تدعم استقلال
تايوان وكان بلينك كذا في اكد اتفاق
واشنطن على الحاجه لاستقرار العلاقات بين
البلدين واضاف في ختام زيارته لبيجين ان
الصين لم توافق حتى الان على استئناف
الاتصالات العسكريه المباشره مع بلاده
مباحثات معمقه وبناء هكذا وصف الرئيس
الصيني
اللقاءات التي جمعت الجانب الصيني بالوفد
الامريكي برئاسه وزير الخارجيه انطوني
بلينكن لنحو سبع ساعات ناقش الجانبان
ملفات امنيه واقتصاديه وتجاريه انتهت
بالتوصل لاتفاقات وتفاهمات بشان عدد من
القضايا
يجب ان تقوم العلاقات بين الدول على اساس
الصدق والاحترام المتبادل امل ان تقدم هذه
الزياره اسهامات ايجابيه لتحقيق الاستقرار
في العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه
الجانب الصيني اكد ايضا على ضروره التعامل
مع الحوادث غير المتوقعه بهدوء ومهنيه
وعقلانيه في اشاره الى حادثه دخول بالون
صيني قبل اشهر الاجواء الامريكيه واسقاطه
بعد زعم البنتاجون انه كان لاغراض التجسس
حادثه تسببت في تعميق التوتر بين البلدين
وارجاء زياره الوزير الامريكي
التوترات في مضيق تايوان والنفوذ الصيني
في منطقه بحر جنوب الصين كانت من اهم
الملفات على طاوله النقاش فالوزير بلينكن
اثر مخاوف واشنطن من اي تغييرات احاديه
الجانب للوضع الراهن في المضيق في الوقت
الذي اكدت فيه بيجي ان احترام مبدا الصين
واحده وسيادتها هو جوهر العلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه
التي يشاركنا فيها عدد متزايد من البلدان
بشان الاعمال الاستفزازيه التي تقوم بها
الصين في مضيق تايوان وبحر جنوب الصين
بشان تايوان جددنا التاكيد على مبدا الصين
واحده وهذه السياسه لم تتغير
بعدم تقديم مساعده عسكريه او تقنيه لروسيا
يمكن ان تستخدم في ساحه المعركه
الاوكرانيه
تتوقع الصين ان تساعد زياره الوزير بلينكن
التي وصفت بالنادره الى بيجين في توجيه
العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه الى مسار
مستقر علاقات تقول بيجين انها في ادنى
مستوياتها منذ عقود وتؤكد بان ملف تايوان
هو الجوهر الاساسي فيها شيماء الجزيره
بيتم
ومن لندن ينضم الينا رودريك الباحث المختص
في الشؤون الاسيويه ما الذي تحقق من اهداف
هذه الزياره لبنكن
وما الذي لم يتحقق
اعتقد ان ما تم تحقيقه هو الزياره بحد
ذاتها كان هناك بعض الشكوك بالنسبه الى
هذه الزياره خصوصا مع الغاءها في السابق
وبالتالي لدينا مؤشرا ايجابي الولايات
المتحده والصين على استعداد لفتح حديث على
اعلى المستويات ما لم يتم تحقيقه هو اي
اختراق مهم او تحصين مهم في العلاقات وما
من رد حقيقيا من قبل الصين بالنسبه الى
الطلب الامريكي المستمر المتعلق بفتح قناه
اتصال لاداره العلاقه بكفاءه اكبر وفعاليه
اكبر الصين لم ترد بالايجاب بنسبه الى هذه
الطروحات الامريكيه ولكن على اي حال كان
هناك مداولات بين الطرفين بالنسبه الى
سلسله من الضياع المهمه وتوصل الى
اتفاقاتهم بالحد الادنى مرتبطه بتحسين
العلاقه بين الشعبين باضافه الى قنوات
اخرى طيب اذا كان اذا كان
الى هذا الخبر العاجل نقل عن رئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ان العلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه تسير في المسار الصحيح هذا ما
يقوله الرئيس الامريكي طبعا هو تصريح عام
لا يحدثنا عن التفاصيل لكن اذا كان الهدف
من الزياره هو اذابه الجليد فهل هذا تحقق
اعتقد انه يمكننا ان نقول ان هذا الهدف قد
تحقق وما اشرتم اليه بالنسبه الى تصريح
الرئيس بايدن ان العلاقه على المسار
الصحيح هذا يساعد ورئيس الصيني
ادلى بتصريح مماثل ولكن يبدو ان الصين
تلقي مسؤوليه اكبر على الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كي تقدم اسهامات ايجابيه بحسب
وصف الصين لذلك اذا يتعين على الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ان تتخذ خطوات في هذا
الاتجاه
الخطوات المطلوبه تتعلق بتايوان تصريح
الرئيس الوزير الامريكي من جديد انه
الولايات المتحده مع تايوان واحد مع رصيد
واحده ومع عدم استقلال تايوان لم يكن
كافيا للموافقه على الطلب الامريكي للصين
باستئناف العلاقات العسكريه المباشره اليس
كذلك
بكل تاكيدا من بين اكبر الامور التي بقيت
مفقوده والتي ارادتها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هو هذا النوع من التحرك باتجاه
ارساء اليات مباشره للاتصال بين الجيش
الامريكي والجيش الصيني كما نعرف تعددت
الحوادث في المنطقه بالنسبه الى الطائرات
والسفن الامريكيه والصينيه من المنظوري
الامريكي يتعين على الطرفين التوصل الى
اليه لاداره هذه الامور كي يتم تفادي اي
التصعيد بالنسبه الى مساله تايوان الطرفان
اعلن عن موقفهما وهو نفس الموقف وما من
تحركا في هذا المجال ولا نتوقع اي شيء
جديد في هذا المجال
الباحث المختص في الشهود الاسيويه ضيفنا
من لندن شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه سيطره قواتها بشكل
كامل على مدينه نوفو دونتسكا في مقاطعه
دونتسك وقالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه من
القوات الروسيه صدت هجوما اوكرانيا ودمرت
نحو 50 اليه ودبابه اوكرانيه خلال القتال
ونشرت الوزاره مقطعين مصورين قالت انهما
يظهران سيطره قواتها على البلده والخسائر
الاوكرانيه في هذه العمليه
ومن جانب الاخر قالت هانا ماليار نائبه
وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه وصلت تقدمها في اتجاه باخموت
خلال الاسبوع الماضي رغم التعزيزات
العسكريه الروسيه في المنطقه اضافه ان
القوات الاوكرانيه افشلت محاولات روسيه
للتقدم باتجاهات الايمان كوبيانس
ومارينكا وقالت ماليار انه في غضون
اسبوعين من العمليات الهجوميه في اتجاهين
برديان
استعادت القوات الاوكرانيه ثمانيه بلدات
وتقدمت في اسبوعين بعمق سبعه كيلومترات
تقريبا باتجاه منطقه عملات عمليات تافريا
كما اعلنت كما اعلنت الجيش الاوكراني وانه
استعاد السيطره على بلده
بيتاخاتكا جنوب غربي مقاطعه في معارك
استمرت اسبوعين
الى اليونان الان حيث عثر خفر السواحل على
جثتين يعتقد انهما الاثنين من ضحايا حادث
غرق سفينه المهاجرين وهو ما قد يرفع عدد
الجسامين التي تم العثور عليها بعد هذه
الكارثه الى ثمانين جثه بينما لا يزال نحو
500 في عدد المفقودين ومن جهه ثانيه استمع
المدعي العام في محكمه كلماتا لاقوال تسعه
مواطنين مصريين يتهمهم القضاء اليوناني
بتشكيل منظمه اجراميه ولاتجاره بالبشر
والتسبب في اغراق سفينه كانت تقل مئات من
طالب اللجوء وقد دفع المتهمون
ببراءتهم ردتهم المنسوبه اليهم
في ملف اللجوء والهجره ايضا قال الرئيس
التونسي قيس سعيد خلال لقائه اليوم مع
وزيره الداخليه وزيره الداخليه الالماني
والفرنسي قال ان بلاده لن تكون حارسا الا
لحدودها ولن تكون موطنا لطالب اللجوء اكاد
الوزيران الاوروبيان قد اجريا محادثات مع
وزير الداخليه التونسي اعلن في اعقابها عن
منح تونس مساعده ماليه فرنسيه بقيمه 26
مليون يورو
الى تونس يشد مزيد من المسؤولين
الاوروبيين الرحال بحثا عن ترتيبات لمعضله
الهجره عبر المتوسط اخر الزائرين وزيرا
داخليه فرنسا والمانيا اللذان اكد ان
الهدف من زيارتهم المشتركه وتعزيز التعاون
مع تونس لوضع حد لعصابات التهريب ووقف
حوادث الموت الجماعي في البحر اجرى
الوزيران محادثات مع وزير الداخليه
التونسي تمخضت عن مساعدات للبلاد على شكل
استثمارات المانيه مباشره ومنحه ماليه
فرنسيه
بقيمه 25 مليون وثمانمائه الف يورو وقد
ابلغت ذلك لوزير الداخليه التونسيه هذا
الصباح خلال حديثنا عن موضوع الهجره
[موسيقى]
ستدفع تلك الاموال مقابل المعدات وعمليات
التدريب اللازمه لوقف قوارب المهاجرين
فتونس تعتبر دوله عبور رئيسيه نحو اوروبا
ويتواجد بالفعل الاف من افارقه جنوب
الصحراء على اراضيها وقد تفاقمت ظاهره
الهجره في الفتره الاخيره واصبحت عب ان
يفوق بكثير امكانيات البلاد الغارقه في
ازمه اقتصاديه وسياسيه ومنذ بدايه العام
الحالي تم انقاذ نحو 26 الف شخص بينهم
تونسيون كانوا في عرض البحر على متن قوارب
متهالكه متجهه نحو ايطاليا الوفد الاوروبي
الزائر التقى ايضا الرئيس التونسي قيس
سعيد الذي جدد التاكيد على ان بلاده لن
تقبل ابدا بان تكون حارسه لحدود اي دوله
اخرى
لا يمكن ان تكون حارسه
لحدودها ولا نقبل ايضا
ان نكون بردا للتوثيق وللاسف بعض
التصريحات التي صدر عن بعض المسؤولين
تشير الى سياسه غير مقبوله على اي مقياس
من المقاييس
زياره وزيري داخليه فرنسا والمانيا بدت
استكمالا للحراك الدبلوماسي الضاغط على
تونس التي استقبلت في وقت سابق رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه ورئيسي وزراء هولندا
وايطاليا يومها حمل الوفد الاوروبي الرفيع
خطه مساعدات بما يفوق مليار يورو مقابل
جهود اكبر في مكافحه الهجره وفي ضوء
التعتيم على هذا الملف اثار العرض
الاوروبي كثيرا من اللغط في الاوساط
السياسيه والحقوقيه باعتباره محاوله
الابتزاز تونس خلال وضعها الصعب وجعلها شر
طي اوروبا
[موسيقى]
فقره المتابعه في حصاد الليله نخصصها
لاقرار الامم المتحده اول معاهده عالميه
لحمايه التنوع البيولوجي والانظمه البيئيه
النائيه في اعالي البحار هذه المعاهده
تؤسس لاطار عمل قانوني يهدف لتوسيع نطق
حمايه البيئه ليشمل المياه الدوليه اي ما
يعادل 60% من المحيطات في العالم وما
يعادل نصف مساحه الكره الارضيه علي البحار
تبدا من النقطه التي تنتهي عندها المناطق
الاقتصاديه الخالصه للدول على بعد 200 ميل
بحري كحد اقصى عن الساحل وهي لا تخضع لاي
ولايه قضائيه وطنيه من الدول المقصود
المياه الدوليه حاليا تخضع نسبه 1% فقط
تقريبا من مناطق اعالي البحار
لتدابير من تدابير الحمايه لكن البلدان
الواقع على اتفاق مونتفيل في ديسمبر من
العام 2022
تسعى الى حمايه الثلاثين بالمئه من
اليابسه والمحيطات بحلول عام 2030
هذه المعاهده معاهده الامم المتحده لحمايه
اعالي البحار توصف بانها خطوه حاسمه
للحفاظ على الحياه البحريه والتنوع
البيولوجي لمصلحه البشريه والاجيال
القادمه لكن ماذا سيحدث بالتحديد مع بدء
سريان هذه المعاهده ستسمح المعاهده التي
تاتي بعد 15 عاما من المفاوضات
الماراثونيه بانشاء مناطق بحريه محميه من
المياه الدوليه هذه الحمايه تشمل النظم
البيئيه للمحيطات التي تنتج وحدها نصف
الاوكسجين الذي تتنفسه البشريه هي الايه
المحيطات تحد ايضا من الاحترار المناخي
وتضم مناطق غنيه بالتنوع الحيويه هذه
المعاهده الجديده تحدد في جانب اخر مبادئ
لتقاسم المنافع منافع المواد البحريه
المحتمله لاكتشافها خلال الابحاث العلميه
في اعال عالي البحار تلزم المعاهده الدول
المصدقه عليها باجراء تقييم للاثر البيئي
للانشطه الجديده في تلك المياه الدوليه
حول هذا الموضوع نرحب بضيفنا من نيويورك
لجيردي
وكيل الامين العام للامم المتحده للشؤون
القانونيه والمستشار القانوني للامم
المتحده سيد سواريز اهلا وسهلا بك
ما هي الخطوه التاليه
في الحقيقه هي حفله توقيع ونحن نخطط لكي
يجري في شهر ايلول سبتمبر ونامل ان عددا
كبيرا من الدول سوف يوقع على هذه المعاهده
وبحاجه نحن بحاجه الى 60 مصادقه لكي تدخل
هذه المعاهده حيز التنفيذ طبعا لن ننتظر
كل هذه الامور البدء بالعمل
ولوضع المؤسسات والهندسه المؤسسيه لهذه
المعاهده العمل يبدا اليوم يوم اعتماد
النص والخطوه التاليه هي خطوه التوقيع
وبعد ذلك الدعم ونامل انه في غدوني سنتين
سوف يكون لدينا عدد المصادقات الضروريه
لكي تدخل هذه المعاهده حيث التنفيذ اذا
دخلت هذه هذا حيز التنفيذ بتصديق 60 من
الدول الاعضاء ماذا عن بقيه الدول دول
العالم هل هي ملزمه بهذه المعاهده رغم
انها لم توقع عليها
المعاهده اعتمدت باتفاق الاراء اليوم وفقط
دوله واحده اعلنت انها لن تنضم الى توافق
الاراء هذا اذا رقم الستين هو الحد الادنى
الحد الادنى لكي تدخل المعاهده حيز
التنفيذ اعتقد ان عدد المصادقات سوف
يتتالى ولكن طبعا هذا يتوقف على تعقيد
العمليات الدستوريه الداخليه هناك بعض
الدول التي لديها اجراءات داخليه بسيطه
تسرع عمليه التصديق على هذه المعاهده اما
دول اخرى لديها اجراءات تتطلب وقتا اطول
ولكن على اي حال اعتقد ان الدعم عارم لهذه
المعاهده من خلال دعم اكثريه الدول
الاعضاء وبالتالي لن يشكل هذا الامر
اشكاليه لا شك انه معروف لديكم من يستغلون
اعالي البحيره لاستغلال الاسوا من الدول
هل تعتقدون ان هذا السلوك سيتغير بهذه
المعاهده
نعم اعتقد ذلك بالفعل واعتقد اننا نتحدث
عن احد اكبر الانجازات بالنسبه الى هذه
المعاهده ان يكون هناك ضبط للاستخدام
المستدام للتنوع الاحيائي او البيولوجي في
المحيطات ونحن نتحدث عن اكثر من
70% من
المساحه المياه التي تعتبر اعالي البحار
وهذا ياتي
بالضوابط المرتبطه بتقييم الاثر البيئي في
المناطق المحميه بالاضافه الى استخدام
مناسب
للثروات البحريه اعتقد ان هذا سوف يساهم
بشكل كبير في الاستخدام المستدام للمحيطات
وفي ضبط جهود الاستفاده من اعالي البحار
هذه معاهده تتحدث عن س من مساحه الكره
الارضيه
مسطحات المائيه هل هنالك اليات كافيه هل
يمكن ان تكون هنالك اليات واقعيه لمراقبه
الانشطه البشريه وانشطه الدول في هذه
المساحات الواسعه من المحيطات
اعتقد ان هذه المعاهده سوف تستحدث نظاما
بحيث يكون هناك انشطه مراقبه واداره
البيانات طبعا
لا يمكننا ان نقول ان كل الدول الاعضاء في
الامم المتحده لديها السبل المناسبه او
الفضله
لمراقبه هذه المساحات ولكن الاسره الدوليه
والهيئات الدوليه التي سوف تستحدث نتيجه
لهذه المعاهده اعتقد انها سوف تقدم
اسهامات مهمه لاستخدام اعالي البحار
بطريقه مستدامه سيد مجال باس وارز وكيلو
الامين العام للامم المتحده للشؤون
القانونيه والمستشار القانوني للامم
المتحده ضيفنا من نيويورك شكرا جزيلا لك
مشاهدينا نصل الى نهايه هذه الحلقه من
برنامج الحصاد دمتم في رعايه الاحيان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]